[Music]
you know a lot of award shows have their
own caddy correspondent to comment on
red fashion carpets red carpet fashions
whatever the audiences are no exception
please welcome our own audiences fashion
assassin james sinclair st wallins
oh god there's a whole shooting gallery
of fashion disasters up there bring on
the first victim
oh
oh no you didn't
i'm not sure where you got those clothes
but out in the field somewhere there's
an angry naked scarecrow
someone should write a best-selling book
about that shirt called 50 shades of
gross next
oh
look at this train wreck looks like
someone just got drafted by the
salvation army
who's next
oh
what a tragedy you must be really into
vampires because that outfit sucks
seriously you look like metallica's math
tutor
you know
i just can't take anymore come on queen
daniel let's go write [ __ ] comments on
dakota fanning's imdb page
thank you everyone hates you
and finally
a lot of people ask how we get such
incredible audiences for this show well
it's all thanks to the tireless work of
our audience coordinator let's take a
look at how he fills our studio with
great audiences
night after night
we're gonna scoop up some new audience
members
what's up you've been chosen to be in
our studio audience today sir
okay what's this for though conan coney
you
i love my job
hold still
you're gonna love it ah we got dustin
diamond tonight
all right here we go here he
is coordinator jesse mackey
[Music]
oh